[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber
guten abend die zahlen von heute liegen
noch nicht vor wir wissen aber dass sich
in deutschland gestern
70.000 menschen eine erste impfung geben
ließen nur 70.000 das sind aber die auf
die es jetzt ankommt auf die gestern die
regierungs chefs und chefinnen von bund
und ländern mit ihren beschlüssen
zielten menschen die sich jetzt noch zur
impfung entschließen 70.000 an einem
dienstag das sind so wenig wie anfang
des jahres als alles noch nach mehr
impfstoff schrie sibylle baslers
reportage zeigt wie wenig das ist wenn
man die sache herunter bricht auf ein
land mit über 80 millionen
jeder der ins im zentrum im bayrischen
geisenfeld kommt wird von peter kurzeck
dem ärztlichen leiter der zeit
persönlich empfangen denn impfwillige
sind hier eine rarität gesamte prämiert
war durch dass die impfbereitschaft der
ort nachgelassen hat innerhalb der
letzten vier wochen
samels gezwungen es zu schließen weil es
auch wirtschaftlich nicht vertretbar ist
in hochzeiten kamen 300 impflinge pro
tag heute sind es gerade mal 10 auch
martina müller ist maßlos enttäuscht
seit monaten ist die arzthelferin im
einsatz und jetzt ist die luft raus
apple schoss er traurig darüber das
schlimme ist wir wissen wir alle nicht
wie es weitergeht tatsache ist in der
august macht das impfzentrum dicht und
bei dem einen wird es nicht bleiben die
impfzentren werden sich verändern müssen
das haben wir gemeinsam in der
gesundheitsministerkonferenz auch
beschlossen wir setzen mehr auf mobile
ins teams die rausgehen die den
impfstoff zu den menschen bringen wir
haben ja dann natürlich auch die
ärzteschaft im boot das ist auch ganz
wichtig die ja weiter in ssten der im
bus des landkreises kelheim die zahl der
impfwilligen schwankt mal sind es 100
mal 30 am tag viel zu wenig so miriam
stark nur klare ansagen könnten das impf
tempo beschleunigen dass man sagt die
die geimpften haben viel mehr vorteile
damit die die sich jetzt zur nicht
impfen lassen haben auch noch in die
puschen kommen es sei wie eine jagd auf
die letzten impfwilligen sagt petra lück
die mehr als 2000 menschen bereits in
ihrer praxis geimpft hat mobile ins
teams brechen sie nun allerdings in die
bredouille moment es unser problem
einfach das zu den impftermin die
patienten teilweise nicht erscheinen
weil sie irgendwo anders schon geimpft
sind und wir haben jetzt die impfstoffe
da liegen und können sie nicht mehr
verwerten 56 impfdosen kann sie heute
noch für impfen den rest muss sie
wegwerfen und das schmerzt nicht jeder
arzt kann die impfungen nebenher leisten
gerade kleine land arztpraxen sind so
schon am limit so stefan skorupa der
pandemie arzt des landkreises
pfaffenhofen ist enttäuscht vom
gestrigen bund länder gipfel dieses in
konsequente handeln der politik klar wir
haben jetzt bald die wahl aber dieses
mit kleinen schritten in die impfpflicht
es ist unehrlich höher oder hot
impfpflicht oder keine impfpflicht aber
so halte ich es nicht für richtig
entscheidungen sind auch ins zentrum
geisenfeld fällig etwa was mit nicht
benötigten impfstoff geschehen kann eine
idee mit den auffrischimpfung bei
älteren jetzt schon zu beginnen ich habe
es ist keine klare anweisung waren die
dritte impfung kommt und wir müssen
klare anweisungen haben wird die
impfstrategie weitergehen soll wie wir
diese vierte welle brechen wollen denn
nur so hätten wir gute chancen die
pandemie zu überwinden
es gab heute erstaunliche unsicherheit
darüber wie viele schon in deutschland
geimpft sind die rk zahlen auf die sich
regierung und medien stützen sind
möglicherweise zu niedrig es könnten
deutlich mehr sein als bisherige
zählungen zeigten das wäre einerseits
eine ziemlich gute nachricht und
andererseits ziemlich irritierend
unterdessen wird weiter corona politik
gemacht und die bevölkerung immer
stärker zur impfung gedrängt dafür
sprechen wohl medizinische argumente
aber zuständigen beteuerung alles bleibt
freiwillig passt es nicht und dann ließ
markus söder gestern abend noch eine
katze aus dem sack es wird in der
realität
auf zweig rauslaufen sagte er dann kommt
man auch mit test nicht mehr überall
rein nur noch 2 gg impft oder genesen
sonst bleibt man draußen diese debatte
hat begonnen berichtet heikes land
es ist das 29 treffen der
ministerpräsidenten mit angela merkel in
sachen corona hauptthema die zu niedrige
impfquote in werkzeugkasten deshalb
daumenschrauben für ungeimpfte kritik
aus der wissenschaft sie setzen
bestimmte anreize verbote erlaubnis und
so weiter 3g 2g und andere methoden um
menschen sanft dazu zu nötigen sich
impfen zu lassen um ein bestimmtes ziel
etwa die überlastung des
gesundheitssystems zu vermeiden zu
erreichen die sprachregelung der
handelnden jedoch lautet kein impfzwang
stattdessen eigenverantwortung mit
konsequenzen so wie beim 1 fc köln
künftig kein zutritt für ungeimpfte das
könnte politisch schule machen wenn auch
juristisch schwierig wir können nicht
heute schon die grundrechte der menschen
einschränken weil wir davon ausgehen
dass möglicherweise eine überlastung der
gesundheitssysteme droht dann wäre
außerdem der erste schritt die
kapazitäten zu erhöhen
freiheiten in absehbarer zeit nur noch
für geimpfte und genießen mit test so
söder könne man keine vierte welle
brechen und genau die sollen hab elfter
oktober kostenpflichtig werden die
opposition hält das für kontraproduktiv
wenn man da den überblick bewahren
wollen wenn der infektionskette
nachvollziehen wollen da sollten wir
möglichst viel testen und zudem ist es
ja auch so dass wir auch wissen dass
selbst geimpfte offensichtlich auch noch
das virus übertragen können deshalb sind
wir dafür diesen test infrastruktur
aufrechtzuerhalten wir werden
insbesondere viele jüngere sehen die
dann möglicherweise wieder privat zu
feierlichkeiten zusammenkommt um den
test zu sparen da wäre es eine gute
investition gewesen noch etwas länger
den test kostenfrei anzubieten
anderthalb jahre pandemie und kein ende
in sicht das impfen als ausweg doch zu
wenige machen mit zweifeln an der
strategie die politik ringt um die
balance zwischen freiheit und
verantwortung der staat muss erklären
warum sollen sich die menschen impfen
lassen wer wird durch ungeimpfte
wirklich gefährdet denn ich glaube wenn
der staat darauf auch eine klare antwort
gibt wird auch die akzeptanz für
impfungen viel größer sein das hilft
viel mehr als jetzt mit mit zwang zu
arbeiten was in meinen augen die gräben
weiter vertieft geimpfte gegen
ungeimpfte mitten im wahlkampf die
politik erhöht den druck und fährt
gleichzeitig auf sicht bis zum nächsten
treffen im kanzleramt
[Musik]
union bedeutet einheit deshalb schmückt
sich die europäische union mit einer
bezeichnung die sie in vielerlei
hinsicht nicht wirklich verdient auch in
einer lebenswichtigen hinsicht nicht bei
impfungen diese karte werden sie im
bericht von florian leu hat gleich
wieder sehen ein beleg für gefährliches
stückwerk hinter einer an sich
triumphalen statistik die union sagt ihr
anfangs verkündetes im ziel sei
tatsächlich erreicht ist es aber leider
nur im durchschnitt das problem ist dass
der schnitt nichts hilft wenn sich
dahinter inseln des versagens verstecken
wo das virus jede chance bekommt neue
brückenköpfe in europa zu erobern und
außerdem ein trainingscamp für neue
varianten
der kampf ist überall der gleiche das
tempo könnte unterschiedlich ja kaum
sein hier sofia hauptstadt von bulgarien
dort mechelen flandern in belgien in
beiden städten sind die impfzentren
gerade ziemlich leer im belgischen
mechelen weil sich hier fast keine
wachsender mehr findet der noch nicht
geimpft ist in bulgarien dagegen man
sich kaum jemand findet der sich impfen
lassen will die impfquote deutlich unter
20 prozent es fehlt an vertrauen seit
der bulgarische gesundheit inspektor um
staatliche institutionen oder in
experten die etwas empfehlen dieses
vertrauen ist an einem kritischen
tiefpunkt
dabei hatte eu-kommissionspräsident in
ursula von der leyen sich gerade noch
gefeiert 70 prozent der europäer
mindestens einmal geimpft
die europäische union hat wort gehalten
und geliefert doch der durchschnittswert
verschleiert ein riesiges gefälle manche
länder hier dunkelt also stark geimpft
andere gerade in osteuropa mit hohem
rückstand da droht ungemach denn trifft
in den mobilen eu eine geimpfte
bevölkerung auf eine weitgehend ungeübte
es wäre genau die mischung in der
gefährliche virus mutationen entstehen
könnten ich habe die befürchtung dass es
dann wieder zu
verstärkten grenzkontrollen vielleicht
sogar grenzschließungen kommen könnte
wenn ein mitgliedsstaat sagt warum
sollten wir jetzt beispielsweise
gegenüber einem land in dem die
impfquote sehr niedrig ist die grenze
ohne kontrollen offenhalten um
geschlossene grenzen wie vor einem guten
jahr ein albtraum auch für brüssel doch
die kommission kann nur zuschauen die
impfungen durchzuführen ist sache der
mitgliedstaaten
weil das nicht überall läuft meint der
konservative bulgarische
europaabgeordnete andere kovacic müsste
die eu kommission sich jetzt deutlich
stärker einbringen
sie kann einen mehrwert bei länder wie
bulgarien
leisten indem sie die gute beispiele von
andere länder
multiplizieren und versuchen also etwa
erfolgsgeschichten wie aus dem
belgischen flandern wo jetzt schon mehr
als 80 prozent der erwachsenen
vollständig impft sind hingegen darin
eine offene transparente kommunikation
seitens der regierung ist enorm wichtig
und zu erklären dass eine impfung im
allgemeinen interesse ist nicht nur
wegen der eigenen gesundheit sondern
auch um künftige lockt 1 zu verhindern
doch ein regionaler erfolg das lied die
geschichte der pandemie reicht nicht
kroner ist erst besiegt wenn es überall
besiegt ist
[Musik]
und nachrichten nun von gundula gause
bahnkunden brauchen geduld erst am
freitag wird sich der zugverkehr
voraussichtlich wieder normalisieren der
streik der lokführergewerkschaft traf
heute vor allem den fernverkehr dort
fielen fast drei viertel aller züge aus
auch im nahverkehr gab es erhebliche
probleme pendler und touristen müssen
wohl auch morgen umplanen die gdl
fordert eine schnellere lohnerhöhung und
eine corona prämie von 600 euro heftige
kritik an dem streik übt die bahn und
fordert die gdl auf schleunigst wieder
zu verhandeln man sei in dem
tarifkonflikt gar nicht so weit
auseinander
im streit um einen stellvertreterposten
im präsidium des bundestages ist die afg
fraktion vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht
vorläufig gescheitert die karlsruher
richter lehnten einen entsprechenden
eilantrag ab im november wollen sie sich
grundsätzlich zu den verfahrensregeln
für die wahl von bundestagsvize
präsidentin äußern die afg ist als
einzige partei nicht im präsidium des
bundestages vertreten alle sechs von der
afc aufgestellten kandidaten erhielten
im parlament keine mehrheit
der innenausschuss des bundestages will
sich erneut mit der flutkatastrophe im
westen deutschlands befassen in der
august sollen auch die
landesinnenminister zu den strukturen im
katastrophenschutz befragt werden das
rheinland pfälzische innenministerium
bestätigte unterdessen medienberichte
wonach ein fehlerhaftes meldeformular in
der integrierten leitstelle trier dazu
geführt hatte dass in der flut nacht
waren hinweise nicht an landesweite
medien gegangen waren extremer
starkregen hatte mitte juli massive
überflutungen verursacht die
bundesregierung betonte dass die
milliardenschweren wiederaufbauhilfen
zügig bei den betroffenen ankommen
sollen
die schweren brände im mittelmeerraum
dauern an neun tage in folge kämpfen die
feuerwehrleute in griechenland nun schon
gegen die flammen inzwischen treffen
immer mehr internationale helfer ein
auch aus deutschland und die lage hat
sich dort etwas entspannt anders dagegen
in algerien wo inzwischen 69 menschen
ums leben gekommen sind viele von ihnen
soldaten die zur bekämpfung der brände
entsandt worden waren besonders
betroffen ist die waldreiche region
kabylei im norden des landes
der sudan will seinen früheren
machthaber al baschir an den
internationalen strafgerichtshof in den
haag ausliefern dem 77-jährigen werden
neben völkermord auch kriegsverbrechen
und verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit
in darfur konflikt vorgeworfen zwischen
2003 und 6 soll al-baschir gegen
aufständische rebellengruppen milizen
eingesetzt haben die systematischen
menschenrechtsverletzungen beginnen
dabei kamen nach un angaben
300.000 menschen ums leben mehr als zwei
millionen flohen vor der gewalt
die deutsche regierung speziell
innenminister seehofer ist heute im
laufe des tages zur erkenntnis gelangt
dass die lage in afghanistan so ernst
geworden ist dass man dorthin niemanden
mehr abschieben kann vielleicht hätte
man das schon früher so sehen können
seit der abzug der amerikaner und ihrer
verbündeten rapide läuft füllt das rot
der taliban gotteskrieger das ewige
schlachtfeld am hindukusch die
hauptstadtregion um kabul ist noch
einigermaßen stabil unter kontrolle der
regierung aus sicht der usa ist es das
ende des längsten krieges ihrer
geschichte eine niederlage die sich nur
mit dem schändlichen ende des
vietnamkrieges vergleichen lässt
präsident biden ist dabei entschlossen
den rückzug den dort trump beschlossen
hatte jetzt durchzuziehen angesichts der
bilder von dort augen zu und durch
ziehen claudia bates berichtet
auswaschen
in den straßen von pfarrer präsentieren
sie ihre grausige trophäe einen toten
soldaten des afghanischen militärs die
taliban feiern ihren sieg über die
provinzhauptstadt stolz präsentieren sie
die amerikanischen humvees die in ihre
hände fielen kundus war der größte sieg
symbolisch strategisch die flagge der
taliban wird jetzt in der stadt in der
jahrelang die deutsche bundeswehr die
stellung gehalten hatte
hunderttausende afghanen im ganzen land
müssen flüchten und haben nur noch wenig
hoffnung
mein haus wurde von einer bombe
getroffen wir mussten weg jetzt sind wir
hier in einem park wir haben niemanden
mehr der uns hilft
auf die amerikaner können sie nicht mehr
hoffen die us regierung sieht das jetzt
als afghanisches problem der abzug der
us-truppen ist fast abgeschlossen und
dabei bleibt es auch diese entscheidung
bereue er nicht sagt us-präsident beiden
geld ja unterstützung jahr aber kein
kampf mehr
wir haben tausende amerikanische
soldaten verloren tod verletzungen die
afghanen müssen jetzt für sich selber
kämpfen für ihre nation kämpfen vom
könig bis zu 130 tausend us soldaten
waren im land aber weder die größe der
truppen noch die us milliarden kamen
gegen regionale strukturen an die
afghanen waren schwierige partner die
taliban nie wirklich weg und das
afghanische militär nicht stark genug
erfolge dauerhaft zu sichern
die afghanische regierung war ineffektiv
und korrupt sie konnte die militärische
entwicklung nicht bewältigen und noch
weniger die wirtschaftliche mann war an
einem punkt angelangt wo man die wahl
hatte unbegrenzt einen gescheiterten
staat zu unterstützen oder sich
zurückzuziehen
letztlich die beiden sich jetzt damit
zufrieden dass osama bin laden tot ist
und die terror organisation al qaida
geschwächt den globalen islamistischen
terror könne man nicht mit truppen in
afghanistan schlagen
wir haben 1000 milliarden dollar
ausgegeben in mehr als 20 jahren
über 300.000 afghanische soldaten mit
modernem gerät ausgestattet und
ausgebildet jetzt müssen die
afghanischen anführer zusammenfinden
die hoffnung also gut auf einem
friedensabkommen gleichzeitig rechnet
der us geheimdienst laut medienberichten
damit dass die hauptstadt kabul bis zu
90 tagen fallen könnte
über die jahre des krieges war unsere
reporterin katrin eigendorf immer wieder
in afghanistan auch noch vor kurzem als
der abzug schon lief und der ausgang
schon abzusehen war sie hat in vielen
teilen des landes menschen kennen
gelernt auch ihre hoffnung dass diesmal
etwas gelingen könnte nach fast einem
halben jahrhundert der kriege katrin da
war eine welt an jahn allianz da waren
unendliche geldbeträge da waren armeen
von weit über 100 1000 männern und
frauen um afghanistan auf die beine zu
helfen wie konnte das alles so enden
nun das hört sich natürlich von den
zahlen und vom aufwand gewaltig an das
problem ist natürlich die struktur und
die ziele die die amerikaner dort
verfolgt haben das problem liegt im
prinzip von anfang an in dem ziel der
intervention das war in irak afghanistan
von al qaida zu befreien und nicht dort
einen demokratischen staat zu schaffen
in diesen krieg sind auch die deutschen
im prinzip mit hinein geraten und haben
relativ spät erst eingesehen dass sie
dort eben nicht als brunnenbauer und
aufbauhelfer tätig sind sondern dass die
amerikaner krieg im prinzip gegen das
afghanische volk angefangen haben zu
führen und die deutschen damit
reingezogen haben also
gleichzeitig natürlich auch das problem
dass die amerikaner pakistan den
hauptstadt der unterstützer der taliban
war bis 2018 militärisch unterstützt
haben also eine doppelstrategie die sich
als fatal erwiesen hat also jetzt hier
alleine auf die großen zahlen und
bemühungen zu verweisen und die
afghanische regierung als alleinigen
schuldigen hinzustellen und die
korrupten strukturen zum problem zu
machen
das ist natürlich nur eine sehr
einseitige sichtweise aber die
amerikaner waren ja nicht allein da
waren vor allen dingen als zweitgrößter
truppensteller die deutschen und da hat
man ja schon erlebt dass die versucht
haben etwas zu tun um eine gemeinde
aufzubauen um schulen zu bauen um
brunnen zu bohren um straßen
infrastruktur herzustellen alles immer
eng koordiniert mit den lokalen kräften
der afghanen warum ist das jetzt so
einfach vorbei und untergegangen
also man hat ja in afghanistan gewisse
fortschritte erreicht vor allem wenn es
darum geht dass frauen und mädchen
zugang zu bildung und zu beruflicher
entwicklung haben die tatsache dass es
eine verfassung gibt dass es halbwegs
demokratische wahlen gegeben hat in
afghanistan also es ist ja nicht nur ein
desaster aber ich denke man hat dem land
zu wenig zeit gelassen man hat die
strukturen in dem land auch nicht
wirklich gut genug analysiert und im
prinzip auch kein keine koordinierte
vorgehensweise
praktiziert also ich sag mal ein
beispiel deutschland noch andere länder
haben sich da im bildungssystem
engagiert haben schulen in dörfern
gebaut wo es zum beispiel keine lehrer
gab während es in großen städten wo es
viele lehrer und kinder gab nicht genug
schulräume gegeben hat also das ist auch
ein teil des scheiterns eine fehlende
strategie wird denn irgendwas von dem
guten wasser auch entstanden sein soll
den nächsten monate überleben können
ich bin da sehr sehr pessimistisch also
was wir jetzt erleben ist der
dramatische zusammenbruch eines ganzen
landes und ich bin selber in kontakt mit
so vielen menschen die ich in den
letzten monaten kennengelernt habe sind
alle verzweifelt die haben angst um ihr
leben fliehen aus dem land die die nicht
mehr fliehen können haben angst um ihr
leben um das leben ihrer familien also
das ist wirklich ein desaster was die
amerikaner dort hinterlassen und man
muss sich vor allem natürlich vor dem
hintergrund dieser enormen finanziellen
des enormen finanziellen aufwand müssen
und auch das enorme menschliche
leid das da entstanden ist fragen ist
das okay das land so zu hinterlassen
war es das wert dann also das ist
natürlich eine frage die jetzt im raum
steht möglicherweise könnte sich diese
entscheidungen in zukunft als eine der
großen außenpolitischen
fehlentscheidungen von joe biden
erweisen eine düstere bilanz dankeschön
katrin vom krieg am hindukusch zu einer
krise der demokratie in europa die
nationalkonservative regierung in
warschau arbeitet weiter konsequent
daran die medienlandschaft von polen in
ihrem sinne zu gestalten und da stört
ein populärer regierungskritischer
privatsender der 1 in direkter ableger
des amerikanischen discovery konzerns
ist er sollte ausgeschaltet werden
dieser schritt hätte einer zu viel
werden können für die fragile allianz
die die regierung noch trägt es geht
turbulent zu im parlament in warschau
zum ersten mal zeigt das system
kaczynski gefährliche risse berichtet
natalie steger der starke mann polens
kaczynski geht siegessicher noch vor der
debatte aus dem saal nach dem motto wir
kriegen die nummer sowieso durch dann
ein wahrer krimi mit einem schmerzhaften
dämpfer für die pis partei die
opposition jubelt kann zunächst die
abstimmung verschieben der kleine
koalitionspartner hatte die regierung im
streit verlassen den ganzen tag über
aber glaubte die pis die mehrheit
trotzdem zu schaffen
das ist ein wirtschaftliches gesetz das
hat nichts mit redefreiheit zu tun
die pis hat bereits seit jahren den
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk in der
hand auch viele regionale zeitungen und
portale die medien reform ist neben der
justizreform zentraler punkt der
nationalkonservativen
obwohl er beherrscht alle staatlichen
institutionen und um dieses system zu
festigen müsst ihr die medien
betroffen vor allem die sendergruppe tvn
privat regierungskritisch hohe
marktanteile schon lange der pis ein
dorn im auge tvn gehört einem us-konzern
aber sendelizenzen für nicht europäer
soll es künftig nicht mehr geben tvn
wäre mundtot gemacht
das ist ein weiterer kritischer punkt in
dem anti demokratischen prozess in polen
ein verlassen von haupt prinzipien der
demokratie
aus dem gezielten medien umbau hat
kaczynski nie einen hehl gemacht
in den medien im internet leider hat die
andere seite die überlegenheit darum
müssen wir uns noch kümmern und die
situation ändern in einigen gesprächen
und wohl mit künftigen attraktiven
pöstchen versprechungen versucht die pis
abgeordnete anderer parteien zu
überzeugen das mediengesetz zu
unterstützen am abend durcheinander die
pis lässt die wahl zur verschiebung
wiederholen und gewinnt dieses mal das
mediengesetz wird danach doch
durchgewunken wenn auch knapp
wir befinden uns in einer solchen etappe
der anarchie des staatssystems in der
der verfassungs rahmen aufgehört hat die
hauptrolle zu spielen
das neue gesetz zum rundfunk ist eine
kampfansage an einen us konzern die pis
legt sich nach der eu nun auch mit ihrem
wichtigsten verbündeten an amerika auch
wenn es für die pis schwieriger geworden
ist mehrheiten zu finden sie versucht
weiter ohne kompromisse ihren kurs
durchzuziehen
und die nachrichten aus der wirtschaft
beginnen mit einer digitalen
räuberpistolen
betrug im internet und cyber
kriminalität sind zunehmend eine
bedrohung jetzt behauptet ein netzwerk
es habe den größten diebstahl in der
geschichte der krypto währungen erlebt
hacker sollen crypto währungen im wert
von 600 millionen us-dollar erbeutet
haben frank bethmann fragen über fragen
wie ist das möglich und wie sicher sind
also kripo währungen das werden sich
jetzt alle die die bei diesem netzwerk
vermögensanlagen in crypto währungen
hatten auch fragen zehntausende kunden
sind betroffen aber was ganz wichtig ist
zu trennen hier ist wenn sie so wollen
eine bank geknackt worden nicht die dns
einzelner crypto währung die noch immer
als sicher gelten weniger sicher
hingegen sind ganz offensichtlich diese
handelsplattformen wie eben pulli
network oder davor plattformen wie die
einst grösste crypto börse mount box wo
damals auch eine halbe milliarde dollar
in crypto währungen abhanden gekommen
sind das sind plattformen auf den nutzer
untereinander mit crypto währungen
bitcoin oder etat handeln bei denen aber
keine regulierungsbehörden oder
einlagensicherungsfonds dahinter stehen
und das macht die sache eben unsicher
können die hacker denn die gestohlenen
digitalen währungen überhaupt nutzen
naja wenn sie schnell genug sind ja im
netz wird derzeit wild spekuliert sind
die hacker clever und gelingt es ihnen
die beute in andere währungen zu
tauschen und so in sicherheit zu bringen
oder sind sie längst aufgeflogen zuletzt
sind fast die hälfte der gestohlenen
millionen an die plattform poly network
zurückübertragen worden ob jedoch
sämtliches geld so kommt ist zur stunde
völlig offen
spannend vielen dank
im echten geldverkehr haben sich die
inflationssorgen bestätigt angetrieben
von höheren energiepreisen ist die
inflationsrate im juli auf 3,8 prozent
gestiegen das ist der höchste anstieg
seit fast 30 jahren im juni betrug die
preissteigerung noch 23 prozent so das
statistische bundesamt
fußball superstar lionel messi hat bei
paris st germain einen zweijahresvertrag
unterschrieben pro jahr für 40 millionen
euro hunderte fans feierten den 34 jahre
alten argentinier in paris der nur eine
von mehreren stars
sein wird neben unter anderem nena und
dem papier messi hatte nach 21 jahren
beim fc barcelona keinen neuen vertrag
mehr bekommen die katalanen sind hoch
verschuldet die
gewinnzahlen vom motto lauten ohne
gewähr 6 12 22
34 46 49 superzahl 1 weitere
gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de und im zdf
text auf seite 15
gleich im anschluss das auslandsjournal
dort können sie die reise des reporters
axel sturm nach erleben wir in sibirien
mit freiwilligen helfern den gewaltigen
waldbränden
entgegenfährt und auch die afghanische
tragödie ist noch einmal ein reportage
thema und um 0.40 wird auch nah sein
möchte mir in unserem heute journal
update nach kabul schauen wir
verabschieden uns ist morgens
[Musik]
guten abend in süditalien wird die
hitzewelle luzifer genannt das klingt ja
schon nach heißer hölle bei uns dagegen
gibt es dieses hoch elfi und das bringt
uns einfach nur schönes sommerwetter und
sonnenschein einen kleinen
spielverderber allerdings gibt das ist
das tief kommt das allerdings erst zum
wochenende von nordwesten einerseits
regenwolken aber auch kühlere luft heran
bringt denn das tief das zieht doch ganz
allmählich weiter nach osten und das
sehen sie hier an dieser neuen grafik
sie sehen hier so einen kleinen pfeil
der bedeutet wie das tief weiterziehen
wird das hoch allerdings das bewegt sich
so gut wie gar nicht und deswegen können
wir heute nacht die sternschnuppen
beobachten per sie ihn in dieser und in
der kommenden nacht sind pro stunde bis
zu 100 sternschnuppen zu beobachten also
schauen sie mal das einzige was ein
bisschen stören könnte sind einige
wolkenfelder im westen deutschlands oder
etwas dunst die temperaturen dazu sinken
in dieser nacht auf 16 bis 10 grad und
steigen morgen an der nordsee auf 23 24
grad sonst wird es sommerlich warm mit
25 bis 32 grad das wird ein sehr schöner
sommertag mit viel sonnenschein und nur
kleinen quellwolken einzig über die
mittelgebirge hier im thüringer wald
oder im sauerland sind die wolken bei
südwestwind auch mal ein bisschen
dichter und auch der freitag wird ein
richtig schöner sommertag mit einer
einschränkung der am späten nachmittag
oder abend kann es dann aus den alpen
heraus einige gewitter geben zuvor aber
wird es richtig war mit bis zu 31 grad
und warm bleibt es auch noch am samstag
aber dann kommt die etwas kühlere luft
hier von nordwesten heran und dann fällt
auch wieder regen im nordwesten guten
abend